CMIKE: Thats a real muzzle flash? NIKO: Thats a real muzzle flash. Roughly the size of the gun. Everybody is always like no way that's too big. No, it's not.
WREN:That gives us four days. I think we can finish all this between the three of us we can finish all this in four days.
NIKO: Okay, cool well
NIKO: That's the case let's talk a little bit about the look of the muzzle flashes and blood hits and all kind of stuff
Am I right ladies?
We were looking at the clip from Eric Andre show you know when they had the blood hits
They basically had an effect on like the person's shirt were like it bulge it up
You know because that's the squib kind of going off
You know and then eventually that would burst this is kind of get the actual like bullet hit effect and all kind of red and gooey in there
And then after had burst you kind of have the splat. You know a blood that didn't go out very far
It makes like something you get from that detonation films hemoglobin
And on top of that you get like a mist spray that would go out really far or really fast
Looking at the timing of our bullet hits not the knife hits of course. But, the actual bullet hits
We want to make sure the timing and the distance travel matches what's on the Eric Andre clip
Yeah, doing a frame-by-frame like seeing in one frame smoke shoots out roughly three feet
You know or two feet or something like that we want to make sure that the speed of our mist hits
I think you have it pulled up right there, which is awesome, but you want to  make sure the speed and the scale that we have matches
What's in there cuz I don't know if the motion is realistic
Yeah
Now in regards to the muzzle flashes the good rule of thumb that Sam and I have always followed which is basically to say
The size of your muzzle flash is roughly
Two-thirds the size of your gun when  it's like pistols roughly the size of your pistol. Like if somebody has like a big assault rifle
It's basically the distance from where the bullet sits in
the gun toward where it exits the gun
The gun is roughly the size of what your muzzle flash should be
coming out of  the gun take note that that first start with the muzzle flash
There is no smoke because the muzzle flash is the smoke the muzzle flash is just the gases that are still hot and glowing
Plasma state basically, so you won't have a smoke where you have a muzzle flash on the frame
and then the next frame once there is no more muzzle flash get to imagine that this gas is expanded even further and
Basically travels out in the next frame to be twice the distance of what the first muzzle flash was so there
We go see how big it is the first term of smoke roughly twice length of gun and then our third frame
It's three times like the gun like see how big it gets. How fast it's very light also which is worth noting
It's very clean burning gun. It's actually a second burst right there now
Lets travel this far into the frame and you can see this flash and that
Force of the smoke traveling that far is what makes guns feel powerful in film
That's why fake muzzle flashes usually look like crap
It's because they don't get to smoke, right
Because you need to imply that there's something inside that gun that has expanded faster than the speed of sound yeah
So there's some great smoke reference right there, you know it expands a little bit for different right here
It's like here than here here. It's all about how it spits that smoke out
that's the other thing like if somebody's shooting next to something adding a little bit of dust flying off the thing is great but the
Lighting also really adds a lot you can really see how much it lights up the scene there That's a real muzzle flash? That's a real muzzle flash. Roughly the size of the gun. Everybody is always like no way that's too big. no, it's not.
It's not people also get shutter speed wrong if there's a lot of motion blur make sure the edge of your muzzle flash is fuzzy
If it's really really sharp,  maybe try to pull it in a little bit, but for the most part
Fuzzy looks ok.  You don't want blown-out muzzle flashes you're filming in the sunlight because you're already exposed to our sunlight
So your  muzzle flashes are going to be a lot softer a little bit more transparent and more colored because you're basically it's like what exposing for fire
Yeah
Not having every muzzle flash be a full muzzle flash also makes things look more real like sometimes you have one frame where it's a
Full muzzle flash in the next frame. You're getting just like a little bits of like fire
Like right at the tip of the muzzle flash like you want to capture a little bit at chaos when you're compositing muzzle flashes
We're not every frame is perfect muzzle flash. Right
Because it's  like the firing rate of guns doesn't necessarily match up with the frame rate of video. Yeah exactly
boom
Wait. It's so much bigger than the gun itself. Wait.
That's real. It looks like there's effects on it, but it's real.  Blank firing guns have bigger muzzle flashes than real guns because there's no bullet
What would you recommend for smoke elements? Like the motion of this pretty good for muzzle flash smoke right? You know it comes out pretty fast
Like if a muzzle flash was this big.
You know that works about, but you have to keep in mind your scale a lot of people composite these wrong
You know shot this far
So they make a gun this big but no like a person just like this tall
This size of a muzzle flash. The gun is like this big. That much smoke. But it's kind of low-res for how big it is but
But usually they're really transparent so it doesn't really matter
That's a real uzi right there.
For our real muzzle flashes.
And he was just firing it one-handed? like a real one
Once again, there's no. Oh here's some real good sparks. It's all real Sparks
I think the thing that spark the stock  footage was especially like CG sparks
Is they never make a little burst at the end when the spark burns out a little like glowing pellet pops
Like a little like fuzzy bursts on the end of sparks, yeah
and so all like sparks have that feeling where it's a straight line and then it pops
and CG sparks can never get that right cuz they never make their particles pop into some more particles in a sub frame animation
That's not Sylvester Stallone's  stunt double by the way. It's just a paint ball. yeah, so what they're doing for those
Sparks is they're actually filling paintballs with
Zirconium which when it hits stuff will spark, so they're literally shooting paintballs spark things that create real sparks
It's so dope. Yeah, it's super cool
Sam Special
Sam Special.That wasn't real?
You gotta love how that shoots of the ground there
BOOM
All that light wrap and glow and reflections and sparks
You see that little bit of gun powder coming out? Yeah, muzzle flashes are dirty
you know so you want to kind of like make it dirty and not to clean let make it muzzle flashes you don't do the
research it's really easy
Like you can go to youtube and you type in gun and you'll find muzzle a flash reference